he is the father of four children
joining me now is Ted Williams former
D.C police detective and Fox News
contributor so Ted you know how is it
that a man like this could survive
Afghanistan serve our country uh just to
be brutally murdered working in D.C
and Katie you cannot wrap your head
around what you've said here this man
nazrat yah was working as a Lyft driver
trying to earn a living for his family
here after coming from Afghanistan after
helping American soldiers there as an
interpreter in Afghanistan came to this
country had four children with him and
his wife trying to earn a living and all
of a sudden his life his whole life is
gone wiped out by some thugs in the
District of Columbia that you cannot rep
ahead around it is very very frightening
Katie yeah and you always have to
remember that when do you hear
statistics there are people behind those
statistics and one DC council member
just admitted this shocking stat
in the first three months of 2023 we had
over 100 cases where people were out on
pre-trial release for violent crimes and
recommitted another violent crime so
that's just an unacceptable number
so there's a revolving door of
criminality and people get let out for
committing crimes and they go commit
more crimes and it happens all over
again
yeah it you know I hear that city
council person but I can tell you just
most recently the city council in the
District of Columbia enacted one of the
most cell phone crime or or Provisions
in the law that you can actually find or
crime Katie in the district is off the
chart this is the home of the Congress
this is the home of the president and
you would think that they would have
crime under control you have more law
enforcement officers in the District of
Columbia than any other place in this
country and still crime is out of
control they've got to do something
about crime it is a national
embarrassment of what is taking place
Katie in the District of Columbia when
it comes to crime and the city belongs
to the country it's the capital of the
United States of America and
unfortunately a man who helped serve
that country is dead as a result of that
criminality revolving door Ted thanks so
much for being here hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else